[Music]
hey guys welcome back to October 3rd
where we just talk about whatever we
want guys I gotta be a proud mama and
let you guys know Isaac recently got
through this another month for honesty
oh we citizen or student of the month
you should keep that on the down-low
with is it good he got honestly cuz they
use it lies a lot compulsive liars are
like when I play basketball and I suck
so much that I got most improved because
I could dribble by the end of the year
of you Isaac the beginning of the year
we were having issues were like yeah he
was lying a lot you had trouble
controlling his emotions when you get
frustrated with homework he like say
things or like just yeah he would just
not what are some sample things you
remember these samples things can you
give us a taste no no come on bring us
inside the darkness of your world that
he said embarrassing as he runs up the
stairs and says mommy mommy I'm citizen
of the month that's embarrassing why is
it embarrassing well just embarrassing
to say that out loud right
like I'm citizen of the month I wish I
had citizen other-- mind what's gonna
sit on the month in my elementary school
the brainwashing starts early okay if
you guys don't see that the government's
[ __ ] smart but alright in my
elementary school on I guess they see
the whole school as like that the
[ __ ] I don't know you like the
country or whatever and you're like a
citizen in this country and the giant
wall in the south end of the school
there's no wall fences it's a whole
school thing every class pics you know
that citizen of the month and then
there's just like a handful of kids that
get that award my dumb ass always
thought it was favoritism and luck I had
no idea like I'm like perfect attendance
this time I'm gonna get
no it was always to me the biggest
sucker you know I was you were I heard
you're still suck up I got you buddy I
got you better we know where the
knuckles oppose me no but yeah I was
just super proud because yeah like I
said in the beginning of the year he was
just not doing that great and then we
got his report card and just everything
is all either outstanding or
satisfactory cuz they don't use ABC does
that make that any more
needs improvement it's like TBD it's
like oh my gosh well what are the ones
its outstanding needs improvement I
think needs improvement oh that's how it
was graded ah yes oh yeah that's like
cooking that's elementary after
elementary school then they know that a
basically the one that I had be worse
than all the other school was gets along
well with others cuz I got I would get
into a fight almost every day non-stop
do you think there's somebody gets out
there who are like one day I will face
my bully and his name is David so no it
wasn't because it was the other way
around so my like a [ __ ] army of I
usually like on [ __ ] Maury Povich and
[ __ ] right exactly it was it was the
other way around so my dad it was so
funny cuz he would whup my ass for
getting into fights in school but after
he will whup my ass he goes don't you
dare let anybody Punk you in school and
don't lose a fight right nobody will
come up and they will put their hands on
me I just go what the [ __ ] and I just
start whaling on him and my dad's like
what the [ __ ] did he beat my ass knee
that doesn't know what you dare anybody
this person's like hey David you look
really tense again needed back oh my god
it was so interesting because I was like
said to dweeby care where that glass
isn't everything you're a good target
then yeah yeah that's a good target so
like every time the target would come
but then I just started whaling on them
and they just wouldn't expect it you
know because it's what my dad taught me
go you can't get punk like what the [ __ ]
we came to this country you guys stick
up for your [ __ ] self
so every time I would get into a [ __ ]
fight and then I got remove from that
school went to another another
elementary school it was all bad you
know
I think I'm like pulling a thing in your
school I do people pick on another kid
like a physical bully like no no one
does that like and what probably could
he's a bully
what grade is he in she's important
there's no bully in 4th grade anymore
that oh my God we're losing the country
we'll leave in the country where are the
kids get alert mental toughness from his
the bullies in his school are the
teachers no or the older kids since his
school is from kindergarten to eighth
grade all saying that the eighth graders
are the ones of the like push and say
hey losers hey Portia Isaac or like
other kids down the track when I was in
eighth grade like elementary kids didn't
even exist
that's weird yeah it's kind of odd they
don't have recess at the same time do
they no they don't
oh I wish they did awesome eighth grade
all these smashes yeah six to eight
Isaac is a special case cuz there's kids
at his school that know us yeah oh
they'll be like Oh Isaac can I get a
photo with you whatever it's like but
maybe he doesn't experience it yeah then
he could get the eighth graders to back
him up oh I see he's in a bubble Isaac
is now makes sense are you gonna look
for a school that has bullying like in
the criteria you're like um looks like
you guys have a no bullying policy I
don't want I don't want to talk at your
school I'm sorry why look I said I
always want my kid he had punched in the
face at least by the time he's - yeah
but I'm he's - he should be in at least
two scuffle I want him to understand
like either like number one I feel earn
how to dodge a hit or maybe not get hit
it off you know have you seen the video
of that robot that has like like legs
that can walk and you like kick in it
like it like gets back up like I'll be
doing that to my kid as it tries to walk
oh just a minute just to make sure I'm
doing that right now you know I'm saying
Tigers like vonda on the bed and he's
like like he's learning how to crawl and
then I just keep pushing from the side
today like this wobbly and then Jill the
other day just like oh so you want to do
that how do you like the other she
starts pushing me oh my god okay
making him tough does he get bothered by
it yeah he's just like yeah yeah he's
such a happy baby he's never like is
there any way to make him angry at all
he's always I don't know but I have this
I have this theory that I think he's a
happy baby because when she's pregnant
she was doing Jake a news and so you're
laughing like like 1012 hours a day
right and I was just think there's got
to be like endorphins or serotonin or
whatever that's like being injected into
him or something yeah hopefully it keeps
it and doesn't turn into a little
[ __ ] [ __ ] he won't you'll go correct
since having kids though do you you know
how there's like nature versus nurture
right do you think there's already a
personality that he came with a little
bit for sure where they're more inclined
to be shy or happy or whatever I think
so as soon as you see babies like you
already get to see their personality
form from like Dave I don't know about
that man because man babies are the most
boring things on the entire because when
their first baby baby is like they're
all the same the minute a baby is born
so for example the minute babies is born
right like his first meal titles like
give me that [ __ ] oh you got that for me
a hundred percent because she's picky do
the eating yeah like from like it
couldn't [ __ ] crazy see what happens
to you it's crazy
you think he eats like you what are you
talking about if you compare a lot of
babies like they don't eat they don't
all eat the same some of them like you
have to feed him like for example you
know aunt right yeah course daughter um
she same thing no I saw and I cook huh
no she she barely eats like she falls
asleep she'll eat like half of what she
takes great it takes for like an hour
two hours to finish it took him hours to
finish tigers killing four ounces in
like three minutes not only that but
even like the way you hold them just a
newborn baby like with Isaac when he was
a newborn or maybe like two three months
old like a little older he didn't like
it when I hold him like this he only
liked it when I held him like like
straight up like this and babies don't
usually like that until they're way
older so they start having their own
preferences like minute they come out
like you look put two babies in the same
PJs one of them is [ __ ] shivering and
then tight this [ __ ] sweat his brains
out already
like he thanked me like he's super hot
my brother has twins and they're polar
opposites and they're twins and they're
so greasy whoo typing he's so sweaty
you're gonna hate pulling out of the
baby carrier this was a [ __ ] jheri
curl in the back whereas if he was
sweating so but it wasn't even hot not
inside the store it was Balkan hot it
was not dude my niece is like two and a
half and she just got interesting to me
like personality wise like she just to
me like it's because they're not yours
the minute like yours comes out you're
gonna be like oh [ __ ] that's from Nikki
that's for me that's what making that's
why I think I'll be smelling the same
crazy sauce everyone else's smelling you
know saying like I think this there has
a lot to do is it no but I know that
it's your truth like I'm not saying that
it's not I just think that there's a
there's a crazy thing happening to you
guys what about your okay your cats
versus other people's cats do you think
your cats are different no how many cats
you have two aren't they different sure
no of course they're different
I'm not saying babies aren't different
but they but they you know like minor
differences but you know okay one baby
gets how a movies gonna flash-forward
like two years later he goes to my kid
is exactly like it exactly right
my kid is [ __ ] six for what's the
same as other kid that's like but see
Nikki does this to where she's like
she's like in my cat the way he looks at
me it's like he's trying to say
something and that's what everyone says
about their dogs and [ __ ] so I just
think it's something we all smell I
think what it is it's I always thought
it was like these creatures babies
animals whatever are blank like canvas
and then our emotions they start
absorbing I mean it that happens too but
they already come out like program yeah
the commercial
it's like Nikki right like she's just
like anybody else when you used to say
like before having tech sense of you
guys used to be like all the parents
like the parenting they [ __ ] up and
both like obviously there's I remember
that a hundred percent yeah there's
gonna be truth in that but then now
your parents yourselves and you see how
the kids just come out their own
personalities no matter how much you
want to like shape it in them for in
other words you want to tell them your
motive I still think if Tiger comes out
[ __ ] up I still think that's still my
fault so I think like yeah they come out
different in different ways and I might
have a kid that comes out to tell a
violent or someone that's really passive
or whatever it's up to me now to like
okay cool how do I just this kid how do
I just a disc yes kids so like I think
my goal is to not make sure doesn't go
to jail but I mean I'm not really
started that's that's low standards but
I I think I think it's still up to the
parent to adapt to how the kid is I just
think no matter what it's your fault
yeah because it's still your genetics
yeah yeah because I know like for me
like growing up I used to have like such
a short short temper you know inviting
the only thing that helped me with that
was the fact that I learned how to
empathize and that's because like
somebody my mom taught me a lot you know
because she was very loving and caring
that didn't change the fact that I
wanted to [ __ ] stab the [ __ ] out of
people almost every [ __ ] day in high
school you don't I mean when people
pissed me off like but as it happened
you empathize I think it was like church
to you let me say okay well I shouldn't
kill this person because it's very bad
like you know during that time to the
guy friends who kill people you know so
for me it's like I can't do this I'm a
good person you know but that's all like
upbringing at that point because I had a
really bad temper
what are you doing Jeff he's making a a
banana sticker joy I'm hearing it damn I
just got a glimpse of you at home with
Jess right now she told you something
serious yeah you're the kid we're
talking about right now it's active
listening they I think girls always need
the most I'm hearing everything they
said you said that you have friends at
church that killed and all that but then
you empathize and you had the Christian
godly upbringing so that balanced helped
you out with your anger problems boom
stickers love it right out of your ass I
can hear
coming out of your ass even great active
listening is important in relationship
is when I found out you have to look in
their eyes
yeah you can't just go uh-huh yeah you
have to be like oh i and then why do you
feel it yeah be engaged the trick is to
have autopilot answers that you can say
while looking at them in the eyes while
thinking of other things that's when
your [ __ ] Jedi relations what the
[ __ ] that's crazy you're like the king
of like that whole round cuz you asked
like the right questions is though know
how good I am
he's actually not even right here what
did we talk about like five minutes go
you don't know I have no [ __ ] idea
he's been thinking about cryptocurrency
the whole whole time and you think he's
engaged I don't even know trust me I
don't even know what we're talking about
right I listen to everything and you
think I'm on a page you could do
something while you're listening mm-hmm
I'm horrible at that you were just doing
that I don't know is that multitasking
yeah cuz I'm here I'm like distracting
myself so I can focus have you ever had
to do that before no it's kind of like
uh alright running and thinking or
[ __ ] and thinking or showering and
thinking sometimes when I'm fidgeting it
kind of helps me focus when I found out
two is set I'm a great listener I'm not
a problem solver like I'm not here to
solve your problems yeah I mean but you
can speak to me as much as you want I'll
listen to the [ __ ] out of your
conversation so like Mariel would call
me in this she's like frantic about [ __ ]
which is most honestly I think it's
[ __ ] you know it's just her just
being frantic and sitting there and she
goes well what am I supposed to do and
that's what I got was like oh [ __ ] me
too I'm like what I'm just trying to
solve this is a problem oh [ __ ]
you've got enough [ __ ] hot sauce let
me give you a pepper chill but the
problem with that is that they don't
want your solutions hell no that's where
the thought like what have you don't
think you're as smart as you think you
are that's the thing about her no not no
no yes it is no
yes it is why won't you listen to my
solutions if it is no because I don't
want solutions all it is is we're
sorting it out so I think guys
internalize it more and they
problem-solve and they do whatever they
got to do internally right but then they
talk it out and because you're our
partner we trust you we're talking our
problems out loud and as we're talking
them out loud then we're sorting it out
and then it all makes sense and we're
like oh that feels good so all we really
need our partner to do is just listen
and be soft and be cute but see that's
that's what I normally thought and the
mariel came with what am I supposed to
do and then I was like that's I pointed
that out to him and I said if I'm not
asking me directly what it like help me
out with this or what should i do then
we don't need it yeah but check this out
right so I gave her a solution right and
then she goes that's not what I want to
hear and I was like okay and so I looked
at this right so I said on the phone I
was like hey you called the wrong person
I think you didn't call somebody else
because you don't know how to help me I
was like exactly so what does that mean
if she wanted your advice and you didn't
say the right it's not black and white
like that though yeah I don't even try
to figure out you can't even try to ask
the questions like that I just told her
you called the wrong person she goes
fine hangs up the phone calls her mom
she goes my mom told me exactly here as
I see so now you know don't ask me that
[ __ ] I'm here to listen for you for
punishing her for asking you exactly Wow
what I learned is that sometimes you
just need to okay okay okay we saw it's
100% of the time 100% I agree yeah
that's what I mean by when I say they
don't think you're as smart as you think
you are because we think that it's not
about intelligence is that we think that
we can solve everything and we [ __ ]
can't and so it's just like you just
have to shut up and hug them and then
and not just that too but you also have
to stop thinking that it's about you oh
yes yeah
the time that's the thing that dudes do
like crazy it's like oh she's being
quiet so I did something wrong and then
like you're further annoying them so
they want you to just [ __ ] leave
right yep
yeah what's that we're learning you
didn't get that no no something right so
so they don't want you to tell them what
to do right they want you to hug them
and shut up and then they also want you
to stop thinking that it's about you for
example like let's say Jill
underperforms or something right and
whatever theme that we have going on now
I go away you're making me look bad but
they're not now it's a selfish point of
view it's about me when I should be
going well what's going on in their life
that's preventing you from performing
the way I've seen you perform before and
that's more about her who's this
[ __ ] about performing know just who
talks this way you're an agent daddy
your own that's the problem those are
crazy about Asian that's always make it
about us I know a hundred percent way
you talk yeah we always make it about
less when it should give the day she has
to bring a report to let me see your
performance report no no no it's funny
more but I do relate with Bart though
where somehow I take offense based off
of people's performance around me yeah
and I'm like where did I get that from
it has nothing to do with me well yes
you know it's so weird I can see where
you get it from because growing up at
least in my household - it was like
that's a reflection of who you are like
who even though I mean I think there's
even studies where they say like you're
wrong who you surround yourself are like
the five people you hang out with you're
hanging around with losers then it's
like I don't want to [ __ ] hang out
with like people that are always getting
50th place right right so I expect more
out of everybody that's a reflection of
you so I can understand like that school
of thought right like I get it but then
at the same time it's like well it's
taken to such an extreme level that it's
like all right well deal with your
issues over there I'm gonna like hug
myself yeah that's why I told Muriel you
called the wrong person go call somebody
up I heard nothing of what we
hey and then you called her back and he
said call somebody I didn't make myself
clear I will say this though it worked
because she called her mom and she fixed
it right up and then we went right back
to our normal conversation
[Music]